[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de dimanche en politique en
direct sur france 3 bourgogne
certains départements de bourgogne
franche comté subissent fortement les
conséquences de la désertification
médicale
le nombre de médecins généralistes
diminue notamment mais pas seulement
les communes rurales multiplie les
initiatives pour attirer de jeunes
médecins au moment où le premier
ministre et la ministre de la santé
viennent de dévoiler une série de
mesures visant à garantir un égal accès
aux soins sur tout le territoire on se
questionne et on en débat ce matin en
direct en compagnie de perrine boulet
député la république en marche de la
nièvre bonjour merci d'être avec nous
françoise tenenbaum conseillère
régionale socialiste déléguée à la santé
merci d'être avec nous également
le docteur richard champeau médecins
généralistes dans l'yonne élus de l'ump
s branche médecins libéraux c'est bien
sûr lui aps l'union régionale des
professionnels de santé merci également
à vous et florie sullerot qui est la
présidente de la corporation des
étudiants de médecine de dijon merci
donc à tous les quatre d'être avec nous
en direct ce dimanche matin vous qui
nous regarde et vous pouvez bien sûr
commenter cette émission sur les réseaux
sociaux avec le hashtag jean paul
bourgogne le gouvernement vient donc je
vous le disais de présenter son plan
contre les déserts médicaux on va y
revenir mais d'abord un chiffre en
france en dix ans le nombre de
généralistes a baissé de 9% alors
mesdames vous ne m'en voudrez part je
vais poser la question généralistes
d'abord pourquoi pourquoi
c'est l'effet conjugué d'un départ
massif des professionnels en retraite et
à une un manque d'attractivité du métier
en libéral pour les professionnels en
formation élus rps est très attentive à
cette problématique et souhaite
accompagner de tout son poids
les médecins libéraux dans la recherche
de leurs successeurs et surtout avoir un
effet et une action auprès des étudiants
donc les accompagner dans leur formation
dans les recherches de stages dans
l'accompagnement la profession et c'est
surtout à l'accompagnement à
l'installation et à un problème de
vocations vous diriez ça c'est pas un
problème de vocation je pense pas que ce
soit la vocation ils sont tous motivés
ils sont tous intéressés par leur
profession vers d'autres voies
ils vont vers la médecine salariée où
ils vont vers des spécialités qui
s'exerce uniquement en milieu
hospitalier par exemple dans les grandes
villes où les villes moyennes non pas
uniquement cela il s'oriente surtout sur
du remplacement qui est plus attractif
pour eux que l'installation le problème
résoudre et résulte surtout de lui
manque d'attractivité et du projet de
territoire et du projet professionnel
dans un territoire la désertification
puisqu'il faut l'appeler comme ça au
niveau des territoires ruraux
avec la perte des structures
administratives et les difficultés liées
à la crise au niveau de l'emploi les
jeunes professionnels sont mariés ou un
conjoint
comment leur trouver un emploi donc
c'est un problème le problème est
vraiment multifactorielles
et il faut que l'ensemble des actions
soient concertés entre les étudiants lui
rps qui va les accompagner les conseils
de l'ordre
les conseillers départementaux la rs et
le rps a toute sa place pour les
accompagner avec des projets dutil cali
alors vous êtes concerné parce que
l'yonne et la nièvre sont parmi les cinq
départements français qui enregistre la
plus forte baisse de médecins
généralistes entre 2010 et 2017 -26%
pour l'yonne -22% pour la nièvre peering
goulet dans votre circonscription
vous constatez sur le manque cruel de
généraliste aujourd'hui dans la nièvre
tout à fait on le remarque très
facilement parce que les délais
d'attentes pour avoir un rendez-vous
quand on est malade c'est deux jours on
peut pas avoir un rendez-vous dans la
journée ce qui fait que quand des
parents par exemple sont inquiets pour
un enfant et qui est en début de
bronchiolite par exemple là il se
retrouve aux urgences donc on a nos
urgences ont doublé en l'espace de
quinze ans sur le nombre de patients qui
passent aux urgences donc on voit bien
que on repousse le tap sable en fait un
come on peut plus avoir de médecin en
ville ben on envoie tout le monde sur
l'hôpital st angor ge et du coup on a
des conditions également dans les
urgences qui sont pas bonnes donc oui ça
se ressent la nef se bat pour pour pour
essayer d'avoir des jeunes médecins qui
viennent s'installer
le conseil départemental a depuis
l'année dernière mis en place une bourse
pour les jeunes étudiants afin que
contre un engagement d'installation dans
notre département et bien ils puissent
avoir 500 euros par mois pour pour
effectuer leurs études on a reçu il ya
un mois et demi la communauté
d'agglomération de nevers a reçu des
jeunes étudiants
en médecine pour leur montrer ce
qu'était réellement la nef pour essayer
de les attirer pour qu'ils comprennent
que l'église alors après a priori ça
leur a beaucoup plu je pense qu'il ya
une vision aussi de nos territoires un
peu lointain puisque en plus on n'est
pas forcément site école on a pas on n'a
pas de première année de médecine malgré
qu'on aimerait bien en avoir sur le
territoire on n'a pas toujours en cours
de discussion
on sait on essaye on continue à se
battre on veut vraiment la voir parce
que derrière il ya pas que la médecine
mais aussi toutes les filières ce que on
parle médecine mais il faut savoir que
dans la nièvre par exemple on a vingt
médecins généralistes de moins que la
moyenne nationale 30 médecins
spécialistes de moins qu'un média
national 40 infirmière de moins que la
moyenne nationale donc voir les
infirmières s'est dit qu'il est bien que
c'est toute la filière médicale et qui
est déficitaire dans notre département
donc il faut vraiment qu'on aille
travailler là-dessus français n'a donc
voilà région vous accompagner notamment
l'établissement les fameuses maisons de
santé on va y revenir dans un instant
mais est ce que vous avez comme ça des
communes qui alerte ce qu'on a choisi
d'appeler cette émission cherche médecin
désespérément qui vous alerte et qui
disent on sait plus comment faire
bien sûr depuis 2004 la région est
investi dans ce domaine là et aide les
communes à se doter de maisons de santé
pluridisciplinaires je vous montrerai la
carte tout à leur aide aussi à la
formation
c'est très important c'est évidemment la
région qui met en place les formations
d'infirmiers les formations
paramédicales voir les formations
sage-femme ou de tinée nous avons aidé à
l'installation d'une formation
d'ergothérapeutes à nevers cette année
c'est important et d'ailleurs pour la
nièvre
nous avons mis en place avec l'éducation
nationale les cordées de la réussite
c'est à dire de jeunes bacheliers cet
été en juillet ont eu plusieurs semaines
de formation préparatoire à la paces
pour qu'il puisse réussir ce concours
est donc réussir leurs études et
s'installer ce qu'il faut c'est motiver
les jeunes de cette histoire là à faire
leurs études et à revenir s'installer et
donc peut-être que l'enjeu c'est de les
aider à faire leur projet professionnel
pendant qu'ils sont encore lycéen est
ancré sur un territoire c'est là que
vous leur dire oui bon ok mais vous
restez par la couarde sacré lieu voilà
parce que nous avons beaucoup
d'étudiants à dijon mais aussi dans dans
les écoles d'infirmer paramédicaux qui
font leurs études en bourgogne ou en
franche-comté et s'en vont ensuite c'est
le cas de mâcon ils s'en vont ensuite se
ronald mais pas c'est le cas aussi de
des nivernais qui s'en vont en auvergne
donc il faut les garder chez nous et ces
grands territoires
il faut les rendre attractifs et ça
c'est tout un travail que nous faisons
avec les communes avec les communautés
commune et avec les départements
c'est à vous que je vais poser la
question mais pourquoi ces étudiants en
médecine dont vous êtes ne veulent pas à
s'installer
souvent dans leur région d'origine et ou
en tous les cas en ont peur vous êtes
originaire je crois du nord côte-d'or
vous connaissez bien ce problème des
déserts médicaux
vous n'avez pas vous personnellement
pour projet de d'exercer dans le cas de
la médecine générale mais vos collègues
là il se pose la question vraiment c'est
hors de question pour eux ne serait ce
que pour leur quotidien leur vie au
quotidien
alors justement je pense pas comme lise
et de touche on peut tout à l'heure que
c'est un problème de vocation il y en a
énormément d'étudiants qui veulent
encore exercé en tant que médecin
généraliste et y en a énormément tout
simplement pour la diversité de la
profession médecin médecin général c'est
une profession qui qui va être très
transversal qui va justement diriger
vers les spécialistes et aujourd'hui on
a encore énormément d'étudiants qui
veulent être médecin généraliste alors
après ce qu'on a l'impression que c'est
le parent pauvre aujourd'hui on sait
qu'on va faire des horaires incroyable
de la route aller voir les gens ici
l'excellent qualité d'installation les
conditions de vie derrière qui pose
problème aujourd'hui et c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui beaucoup d'étudiants
remettent en question leur choix de
médecins d'être médecin généraliste plus
tard parce qu'il ya toutes ces
conditions qu'ils vont jouer aujourd'hui
quand on est dans des dans des campagnes
il faut savoir que c'est pas qu'un
problème de médecins c'est un problème
de secteur public d'une manière générale
il ya les boulangers qui disparaissent
il ya les petits commerces qui
disparaissent
je veux dire je le sais je
une heure de bus tous les matins pour
aller à mon lycée vous vous dire et
j'avais pas de bus par exemple on était
obligés d'aller jusqu'à un certain
village pour avoir un but c'est le lycée
et c'est tous les secteurs qui
disparaissent pas seulement les médecins
et aujourd'hui pour attirer les médecins
dans les campagnes
il faut aussi ré à tirer tout le secteur
public parce que un c'est à dire un
médecin dira un médecin aujourd'hui je
viens m'installer dans une campagne
oui certes la campagne et moi
personnellement j'ai vécu j'adore la
campagne et j'aimerais plus tard avoir
ma vie à la campagne
voilà élever mes enfants à la campagne
pourquoi pas mais le problème
aujourd'hui c'est que quand on annonce
un médecin ben oui faut bien vous
installer dans ce petit village mais bon
vos enfants c'est tout ça qui est
compliqué aujourd'hui et je pense que
c'est pas seulement des airs mais qui
entendent les politiques sur cette
réaction de floris euros vous connaissez
bien ces problèmes de ruralité berings
voulait un moment donné on fait comment
parce que poursuit hantise et dire aux
jeunes
allez-y allez vous installer dans le
rural mais en même temps effectivement
la vie au quotidien peu de vite devenir
un enfer pour ces gens qui ne sont pas
de là et qui viennent s'y installer pour
travailler mais je partage complètement
ce qu'il vient de dire effectivement un
jeune médecin comment lui dire venir
s'installer si s'il n'y a pas de viviers
d'emplois autour pour son conjoint s'il
n'y a pas d'école pour accueillir ces
enfants
si effectivement pour aller à la
boulangerie faut faire 20 km c'est pour
ça que c'est très important que l'on
puisse garder nos écoles le ministre de
l'éducation nationale s'est engagé à ne
pas fermer d'école dans dans les
territoires ruraux donc ça faut bien
qu'on est dessus qu'on aménage ces
choses là
et puis bon jeu dans notre département
ils sont en train de mettre en place une
cellule d'accompagnement justement pour
les conjoints de personnes parce que
c'est les médecins ne sait pas que les
médecins ont peine à voir des gendarmes
à château chinon parce que les conjoints
n'y a pas de travail on peine à faire
venir tous les pros ciel comme ça qui
sont en mutation régulière dans le cadre
de leur métier où il faut à chaque fois
que le conjoint suivent qui trouve un
métier est donc là ils ont ils viennent
de mettre en place la dent il ya
quelques sillac la semaine dernière il
me semble une cellule pour accompagner
voilà toutes ces personnes qui mute pour
pouvoir au moins trouvé le travail et la
c30 finalement on voit que c'est un
problème plus global de nos territoires
mais concrètement qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire c'est un peu le serpent qui se
mord la queue s'il n'y a pas de commerce
il ya plus de services dits flory moi
mes camarades à l'université ils vont
pas vouloir s'installer dans ces
territoires ruraux
alors il ya des choses il ya la
profession médicale ou paramédicale
parce qu'il faut parler maintenant des
équipes de soins de proximité mais parce
que vous dites vous votre votre
leitmotiv c'est une structure commune on
va y venir avec les maisons de santé
c'est aussi une façon de s'entraider
d'avoir moins l'administratif à gérer ou
du moins de mettre en commun certains
nombres d'administratifs et de frespech
financé par l'assurance maladie par
exemple et on travaille ensemble on
partage les mêmes fichiers de patients
on peut se remplacer pour aller en
formation ou prendre des congés
bref c'est plus facile et puis on n'est
pas tout seul il yal kiné qui va pouvoir
prendre la relève
il ya les services sociaux qui vont
pouvoir aussi gérer le malade qui rentre
à domicile tout ça est important
travailler en équipe mais il ya aussi
les médecins libéraux classiques il faut
pas les oublier
si un médecin veut s'installer seul et
bien c'est bien qu'il s'installe on
l'aidera aussi cela est important il
faut pas dénaturer les choses mais les
territoires de choses alors le médecin
talant libéral ou alors il ne veut pas
s'installer en libéral
il remplace yal'idée la saône et loire
qui le département commencent à
embaucher une trentaine de médecins pour
ensuite leur demander d'aller travailler
dans les maisons de santé
c'est une solution les hôpitaux font
aussi des assistants partager c'est à
dire des médecins hospitaliers passeront
une partie de leur temps à l'hôpital
l'autre partie dans une maison forte et
puis in fine et essayons de ramener de
la population dans ces territoires
ces territoires sont magnifiques et bien
depuis plus d'un siècle la police la
population mais dans le monde entier
accourent vers les villes essayons est
incitatif et de chercher comme dans le
mille en limousin à faire revenir des
familles il ya du travail
moi je vous propose justement puisque
vous en parlez puis je donnerai la
parole au docteur champeau dans un
instant pour qu'ils réagissent à ce
projet notamment et à vos explications
dans la saône et loire le conseil
départemental veut donc créer un service
départemental de santé avec des médecins
salariés dans les zones délaissées
à l'image du village de pierreclos un
reportage réalisé au mois de juin mais
qui reste toujours d'actualité la
commune cherche toujours des médecins
regarder pierreclos une petite commune
de 950 résidents niché dans le val
lamartinien un cadre de vie agréable
sauf sur le plan médical car depuis le
1er janvier le médecin généraliste est
parti créant ainsi une galère pour les
habitants c'est embêtant ouais on aime
bien voir un médecin dans chaque commune
qu au lot c'est très compliqué quand
même faut aller aux urgences à l'entrée
de la commune
une grande banderole est installé comme
un cri de détresse c'est la seule
solution qui a trouvé monsieur le maire
pour faire venir un médecin car même la
présence d'une maison médicale ne suffit
pas à attirer un généraliste quelques
touches mais ça pas fait
ça ça peut faire mal on n'a pas su on
n'a pas plus répondre favorablement à
leur demande
financièrement c'est des médecins qui
veulent travailler à mi-temps ou chez
des médecins
ça leur corrige pas pour eux
alors pour lutter contre la
désertification médicale
le conseil départemental de saône et
loire a décidé de frapper fort en créant
un centre de soins départemental avec 8
à 12 ans thème dans les zones en
souffrance et pour ce faire
trente médecins seront recrutés on va
travailler évidemment sur un modèle le
plus souple possible fidéliser les
patients et leurs médecins
départementaux ne pas faire concurrence
à la médecine libérale l'objectif n'est
pas là on veut venir en complément
si un jour des médecins libéraux veut
s'installer sur a lieu et bien la phrase
structure départementale va se rassurer
et laissera la place aux médecins
libéraux ce que l'on souhaite c'est
vraiment être complémentaire sous et
complémentaires aucune estimation du
coût de l'opération n'est pour le moment
disponible mais le dispositif devrait
être mise en place à compter de début
2010 m du côté de la saône et loire
reportage signé damien bouthillier
champeau vous regardez ça un peu en vous
inquiétant parce que c'est est ce que
c'est la fin de la médecine libérale
dans les territoires ruraux où
finalement le président du conseil
départemental de saône et loire s'en
défend il dit nous on va faire quelque
chose de très flexible et puis on
s'effacera au moment où un médecin
libéral veut s'installer
je pense que c'est plus compliqué que ça
et ça nous inquiète quand même qui peut
sur la le modèle économique le modèle
économique qui a meta salariés à 35
heures plus les congés plus les
remplacements
le secrétariat si on veut être
performant le fait que le médecin ne
soit là éventuellement que deux jours
par semaine pour le suivi des
pathologies chroniques
on en a fait l'expérience si on en fait
l'expérience au quotidien des médecins
du chu qui sont détachés sur les
hôpitaux périphériques pendant trois
mois on a à pendant les trois mois
suivants on a b pendant le cap des trois
mois suivants on en a un autre facile
deuil de la médecine libérale certain
vent
rurale parce que c'est quand on écoute
françois serrano madiba il y aura
peut-être des gens qui seront détachés
du chu deux jours par semaine
non il faut absolument pas faire le
deuil de la médecine libérale c'est elle
je pars en conséquence on râle en zone
rurale je pense que il faut surtout
consolider et conforter l'existant on
est vraiment en état d'urgence absolue à
ce niveau-là créé ressusciter des
patients décédés
les anesthésistes qui savent pas faire
on sait et on l'a montré dans le cas des
attentats dans les état d'urgence
absolue
on arrive à mettre en place les moyens
et les moyens c'est la conjonction des
services de la préfecture des services
fiscaux du conseil départemental de l'ud
rps qui va accompagner ces futurs
médecins parlent et la cellule d'appui à
l'installation
c'est la formation qui doit évoluer
également comme la profession doit
évoluer mais c'est une urgence et les
mesures de la ministre sont les
bienvenus mais il faut absolument
qui est ce ce pacte est cette alliance
entre les services pour que ça ne
demande pas des mois et des mois et là
vu le pompon là c'était les zones de
revitalisation rurale
la modification des projets
professionnels je suis dans le même cas
chez la maison de santé
on avait un projet professionnel des
projets avec deux autres médecins et
puis on a perdu le statut de zone de
revitalisation rurale
suite au changement ce n'est plus aux
communes excellé aux communautés de
communes mais ça casse tout ce qui était
fait les dix dernières années a été
annulée par cette mesure
je du président du conseil départemental
de saône et loire vous depuis la région
vous le regardez comment on rappelle ce
sont des initiatives individuelles bring
me disais que ça n'existerait peut-être
aussi dans la nièvre
moi je crois qu'il faut tout essayer oui
il faut tout essayer
il faut rien refuser et voyons si ça
marche parce que vous n'êtes pas du tout
de la même couleur politique d'ailleurs
tout à fait tout à fait vous moi je
regarde ça avec bienveillance et si ça
marche tant mieux
et puis ensuite au delà de ces médecins
la cie des jeunes veulent venir
s'installer
ils ont dit qu'ils opposeraient leur
médecin parfait
cette idée et je pense que lui rps à
effet de rencontrer le président du
conseil départemental et a fait la
proposition suivante c'est que
effectivement l'idée de fidéliser la
patientèle sur une zone
mais c'est ensuite la repasse sur le
monde libéral et il faut que ce soit
anticipée sur le projet et que le comté
départementale puisse arriver à échanger
avec les rps qui sera force de
proposition à 7100 c'est ce que dit
andré accary pouvais pas être avec nous
aujourd'hui mais c'est sa vision c'est
quelque chose de très très souple moulin
a fait des propositions vous dit que ça
pourrait exister dans la nièvre
peut-être évidemment la présidente du
conseil départemental mais mais vous
suivez ce dossier j'imagine par contre
c'est pas du tout dans les propositions
de madame d'user ses services
départementaux de santé une priorité
pour la république je vous voyais
d'autres choses mais oui nous on veut on
voit d'autres d'autres choses c'est à
dire moi je pense qu'il faut
individualisé l'installation des jeunes
médecins par rapport aux médecins qui
veut s'installer
monsieur le disait très bien tout à
l'heure il ya des jeunes qui vont
vouloir travailler à temps partiel comme
il le disait là il faut qu'on puisse
leur permettre de travailler à temps
partiel donc là les structures d'accueil
multidisciplinaire où on veut doubler
les maisons de santé plein d'isner ça
peut être une réponse
on a également des médecins qui
souhaitent et bien travaillé tout seul
on peut pas les arrêter je pense que
c'est important
il ya des médecins qui veulent aussi
avoir une alternance dans le métier pas
tout le temps être généraliste donc les
contrats de médecins
partagé entre l'hôpital et puis les
territoires c'est intéressant il faut qu
on individualise l'offre par rapport à
ce que le médecin a envie de faire et de
danser pour ça qu'on a un panel d'offres
sur sur l'accès aux soins dans le dans
la proposition de madame busin qu'ici on
a donc les maisons de santé
pluridisciplinaires a multiplié par deux
on à l'accompagnement des jeunes qui
veulent s'installer tout seul avec un
nouveau zonage pour augmenter bien la
partie où les jeunes vont pouvoir
s'installer bénéficier des aides
on a également pour les aider à
s'installer mais quand il ya des
médecins qui veulent partir
l'aide au cumul des retraites pour les
médecins qui veulent partir donc il faut
vraiment c'est pour ça qu'on a tout un
panel
alors on va pas tout les annassers mais
on avait l'impression qu'aujourd'hui
agnès buzyn présente sa réforme pour la
sécurité sociale dans le jdd en et en
direct ça tombe bien on peut en parler
c'est pas un peu contradictoire la
semaine dernière on essayait de
débloquer des fonds pour doubler les
maisons médicales on sait bien qu'elles
ne sont pas financés entièrement par les
parle par le budget de la sécurité
sociale mais quand même on a vu que
l'assurance-maladie prenait sa part et
résultat des courses aujourd'hui ronde
il faut serrer les vis alors non c'est
pas faire les deux oui on peut faire les
deux parce que si on remet par exemple
des médecins en zone rurale
eh bien on peut baisser le coût des
transports pour emmener un malade d'un
lieu à un autre si le médecin plus
proche de lui on va faire des économies
sur le transport
donc on a aussi la télémédecine on a dit
dans le dans le plan de renforcement du
soin partout en france qu'on voulait que
chaque ehpad et un siège 2 et médecine
pourquoi les parce qu'une personne âgée
quand on a besoin de l'emmener voir un
médecin
mais il faut un personnel qui viennent
avec elle souvent une aide-soignante un
véhicule souvent de type dsl pour
l'emmener et après la consultation
donc on voit qu'on peut faire des
économies d'échelle en investissant au
départ alors il nous reste quatre
minutes d'émission on va aller très vite
floris euros vous quand vous voyez ces
propositions n'ont plus de maison de
santé
peut-être du temps partagé faire des
choses différentes vous pensez que ça
peut séduire plus les jeunes de se
retrouver en monde rural 24 24 70 heures
par semaine
alors oui tout à fait les maisons de
santé pluridisciplinaires aujourd'hui
clairement
on a sondé nos étudiants en avril
justement pour une réunion qu'on avait
fait avec l'ordre des médecins pour
justement parler des déserts médicaux en
bourgogne franche comté donc c'est
quelque chose dont on a déjà parlé et
aujourd'hui on n'a que je vais vous dire
les chiffres 95 % d'étudiants qui sont
prêts à s'installer dans les maisons de
santé pluridisciplinaires
mais justement il faut pas non plus
laisser de côté les étudiants qui
veulent quand même donc les futurs
médecins qui veulent s'installer seuls
parce qu'il y en a encore
et aujourd'hui quand on pose la question
d'une manière générale qu'on demande des
chiffres il ya quand même 10 %
d'étudiants qui veulent s'installer en
libéral seules les maisons de santé vous
les accompagnez vous à la région voilà
vous êtes venu avec cette petite carte
c'est pour nous montrer qu'elle a déjà
beaucoup en fait 96 sur la bourgogne
franche comté
donc nous n'avons pas attendu madame
d'eysines pour en mettre en place bien
sûr il faut certes voir que les autres
planeurs côte d'or et le nord de l'yonne
manque encore y en a encore des zones
vides en maison de santé par
l'acquisition pour les maisons santé on
voit bien vous nous dites qu'il en
existe déjà 96 et le problème demeure
puisqu'on en parle encore aujourd'hui
est donc effectivement il n'ya pas que
ça il faut inciter les professionnels à
s'y installer
inciter ceux qui veulent travailler en
libéral a continué à travailler en
libéral et la télémédecine c'est très
bien mais y'a qui derrière pour regarder
les images
allez au musée beaucoup parce qu'on
finit bientôt cette émission mais agnès
buzyn n'a pas voulu changer le numerus
clausus je propose la question à florida
mans et puis au docteur champeau
rapidement mais je pense que le numerus
clausus déjà il faut savoir quand on
change le numerus clausus a appris en
effet dans le dix ans donc là dans
l'immédiat numerus clausus wallace et
prenez ça c'est pas forcément la
solution surtout que numerus clausus
faut quand même savoir que c'est des
bases certif on répondra
à la demande de soins mais il faut aussi
pas oublier que nous après il faut qu'on
soit formé et demandé à bill et capacim
futurs médecins de donner cinq ans dans
le rural et c'est par un classement
national quelque chose comme ça ça
serait pertinent pas du tout commença
classement national avec les premiers
choisissent vous savez comme dans plein
de femmes profession au delà du numerus
clausus ya déjà aujourd'hui le
classement nationaliser cnc l'inflation
nationale où on choisit nos spécialités
et moi choisir
j'entends juste pour la maxime avez-vous
pensé à inclure du coup les plats
géographie dans le choix de la langue
général ça veut dire ne plus laisser la
liberté d'installation des médecins
libéraux et je pense pas que faire une
des raisons pour laquelle aussi la
médecine libérale c'est la liberté
d'installation en 50 secondes
donc je partage la position de flory je
pense qu'il est important de l'urgence
est ce que je disais tout à l'heure de
maintenir et d'encourager ceux qui
restent et ceux qui fonctionnent
c'est absolument indispensable
d'améliorer la formation et que c'est
une action collective qui nous ya que ça
qui pourra améliorer les choses si les
acteurs ne se mettent pas d'accord là
dessus je pense que quelle que soit la
mesure
on ira à l'échec et du rps et bien force
de proposition sur ce métier on va
essayer de suivre tout ça bien sûr sur
notre antenne merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat dans un instant
l'essentiel de l'actualité en bourgogne
avec arnaud lefebvre pour la partie
nationale de dimanche en politique vous
retrouverez francis letellier qui reçoit
le ministre de l'économie et des
finances bruno launay le maire
bon dimanche à tous
[Musique]
c'est